It's been almost a decade since Marvel's Iron
Man made superhero movie skeptics sit up and
take notice, and the comic book movie craze
isn't going away anytime soon.
There are a slew of superhero flicks scheduled
to hit cinemas over the next few years, but
as franchises continue to expand, it becomes
harder and harder to keep track of what's
happening and who's who.
"Wait a minute you guys aren't the real Avengers,
Hulk gives it away."
This is everything you need to know about
upcoming superhero movies through the end
of 2018.
Thor: Ragnarok
Chris Hemsworth will reprise his role as the
hilariously heroic Asgardian god in Marvel's
Thor: Raganarok, and Tom Hiddleston will be
back to make sure no new villains take over
his spot as number one fanboy villain, though
he'll face stiff competition from Cate Blanchett.
The British Oscar winner comes on board as
Hela, goddess of the underworld, who might
just be the best Marvel villain yet.
The film takes a cue from the surreal visuals
of Doctor Strange, and looks like it's been
pulled right out of the comic pages, which
is a good thing.
And with director Taika Waititi at the helm,
Ragnarok's November 3rd, 2017 release date
can't come soon enough.
Thor agrees.
"I'm not up to much at the moment.
What are you doing later?"
Justice League
If the future of DC films relies on any one
project, it's Justice League.
The eagerly awaited team-up of DC's greatest
heroes could make or break the Extended Universe
after its rocky start.
Equaling the success of Marvel's Avengers
is the basic goal for DC here, and director
Joss Whedon is on board to help make that
happen.
Whedon has agreed to shepherd Justice League
through post-production and will also shoot
some additional scenes, still aiming for the
original November 17th, 2017 release date.
Ben Affleck, Henry Cavill and Gal Gadot will
be joined by Jason Momoa as Aquaman, Ezra
Miller as The Flash and Ray Fisher as Cyborg.
Irish actor Ciaran Hinds confirmed that he's
playing classic villain Steppenwolf via motion
capture.
With one of Darkseid's main men finally onscreen,
can Darkseid be far behind?
And will DC films finally lighten up a little?
"Dressed like a bat.
I dig it."
We hope so.
Black Panther
While we're not sure how the big screen version
of Wakanda will differ from Stan Lee and Jack
Kirby's comic book vision of a high-tech jungle
world, we'll find out on February 16th, 2018.
After a handful of screenplay edits and juggling
directors, Marvel secured Creed director Ryan
Coogler, and the sizzle reel for Black Panther
which recently screened at Marvel's Los Angeles
offices reportedly had everyone very excited.
Joining Chadwick Boseman as Black Panther
will be Lupita Nyong'o, Forest Whitaker, Angela
Bassett, and Creed's Michael B. Jordan, who
said that Black Panther will be a "very honest
and gritty" movie.
How that will fall in with comedic action
fare like Guardians of the Galaxy and Ant-Man
is anyone's guess, but with Andy Serkis' evil
Ulysses Klaw showing up, anything is possible.
New Mutants
Fox has handed the reins of their X-Men spinoff
franchise to filmmaker Josh Boone, who admitted
to being "obsessed with Marvel Comics."
He took it upon himself to convince the studio
to put the New Mutants on the big screen,
and alongside co-writer Knate Gwaltney, they
put together their own New Mutants comic book
based on stories they wanted to adapt for
Fox.
The studio loved it.
Fox recently confirmed a release date of April
2018, with Game of Thrones vet Maisie Williams
signed on to play the hairy mutant Wolfsbane,
and The Witch star Anya Taylor-Joy signed
on to star as Magik, sister of the X-Men's
Colossus.
Stranger Things star Charlie Heaton will portray
the jet-powered mutant Cannonball, 13 Reasons
Why actor Henry Zaga is signed on as Sunspot,
and newcomer Blu Hunt will take on the part
of Native American mutant Moonstar.
Rumor has it that they'll be up against one
of Marvel's weirdest villains, and one of
their early adversaries: the Demon Bear.
And everyone knows that bears are bad news.
"I'm sick of these constant bear attacks.
It's like a freakin country bear jamboroo
around here!"
Avengers: Infinity War
Good news, impatient Marvel fans: Infinity
War will be a standalone movie, and not broken
up into two films released an excruciating
year apart as originally thought.
Directors Joe and Anthony Russo cleared up
the confusion, admitting that the working
titles were "misleading."
And we'll see it all on May 4th, 2018.
MCU fans know to expect to see just about
every Marvel superhero appearing in a battle
against Thanos, and behind the scenes footage
from Marvel as confirmed Star-Lord actor Chris
Pratt on set with Robert Downey Jr. and Tom
Holland.
Brie Larson's Captain Marvel is also set to
make her MCU debut.
Marvel is positioning the two upcoming Avengers
flicks as the culmination of everything they've
been working toward since the first Iron Man
movie dropped in 2008.
Marvel's Joe Russo confirms the hype.
"These next two Avengers films will be an
event like no one has seen on film before."
Marvel Studios head honcho Kevin Feige also
addresses their well-documented villain issue.
"Thanos shows us why he is the biggest, the
best, the baddest villain that we've ever
had."
What should we expect in Infinity War's sequel?
The Russos have revealed that they're considering
as many as 67 well-known Marvel characters
to round out the film's incredible roster.
The title of the sequel was being kept under
wraps at Marvel, though Guardians of the Galaxy
star Zoe Saldana recently dropped a huge hint
by mistake.
"And we all have to go back for Gauntlet later
this year."
Does that mean Avengers 4 will be called Infinity
Gauntlet?
All we know is that one of those 67 Marvel
characters had better be MODOK.
"Surrender to MODOK!"
"Seriously dude, you've got baby arms and
legs!"
Deadpool 2
After 2016's Deadpool became the highest-grossing
film in the X-Men franchise, keeping the creative
team together for the follow-up seemed essential.
But director Tim Miller has departed the sequel,
allegedly because star Ryan Reynolds didn't
back his demands for a larger budget.
David Leitch of John Wick fame has since stepped
up to direct, and Josh Brolin will be welcomed
into the fold as the Merc With a Mouth's time-traveling
foil, Cable.
Jack Kesy, best known as philandering rocker
Gabriel Bolivar in FX vampire series The Strain,
has reportedly signed on as the villainous
mutant Black Tom Cassidy.
And because it wouldn't be Deadpool without
his reluctant, accidental sidekicks, Stefan
Kapicic and Brianna Hildebrand will return
as metallic X-Man Colossus and his understudy
Negasonic Teenage Warhead.
Prepare to be offended in the best possible
way on June 1st, 2018.
The Incredibles 2
After veering off into live action, Pixar
legend Brad Bird is set to return to his bread
and butter with a follow up to his 2004 animated
superhero smash, The Incredibles.
A second outing with the Parr family was first
announced in 2014, a decade after the original
film, with a 2019 release date penciled in.
When pressed for details, Bird said,
"I don't like unwrapping presents before Christmas.
[The film is] very actively moving, and we're
excited about it.
[We're] trying to take it in some new directions."
Just a few months later, Frozone voice actor
Samuel Jackson was posting photos to Instagram
from his Incredibles 2 recording session,
and the film's much-anticipated release date
had been moved forward to June 2018, with
Toy Story 4 pushed back to make way.
Ant-Man and the Wasp
Kevin Feige recently confirmed that the sequel
to 2015's Ant-Man would go into production
in summer 2017, with the aim being to wrap
in time for a release by July, 2018.
Michael Douglas confirmed that he'd be returning
as Hank Pym, and he won't be the only returning
member of the supporting cast, with Michael
Pena and David Dastmalchian also set to reprise
their roles, alongside Paul Rudd and Evangeline
Lilly in the titular roles.
Returning director Peyton Reed seems excited
about the film, particularly about introducing
The Wasp to the MCU, saying,
"For me as a comic nerd, I always thought
of Ant-Man and Wasp as a team and that's a
lot of what the second movie is really about.
To show her finally fully formed in this movie
is really exciting."
Venom
Sony has been trying to produce a Venom movie
for over a decade, but we now finally have
confirmation that the studio is prioritizing
the project, pushing for an October 2018 release.
Powerhouse Tom Hardy has signed on to play
the lead role of Eddie Brock, the first villain
to take on the Venom symbiote suit in Marvel
comics.
Sony confirmed the casting when they tweeted
a photo of Hardy wearing a Venom t-shirt along
with a caption that revealed production is
set to start this fall.
Directing duties have been offered to Zombieland's
Ruben Fleischer.
Producers are hoping Hardy is better received
by fans than Sony's previous Venom, played
by Topher Grace, as Hardy's set to play a
central role in what they're calling the Sony
Marvel Universe.
Hardy will be working from a script penned
by Scott Rosenberg and The Amazing Spider-Man
2 co-writer Jeff Pinkner.
X-Men: Dark Phoenix
Fox has announced the 12th film in their X-Franchise,
based on the life and death of Jean Grey,
loosely centered on the events around the
Uncanny X-Men story arc of the same name,
and the cosmic force responsible for Grey
going a little crazy.
X-Men: Dark Phoenix is set to open in November
2018.
Few other details are known at this stage,
though an Instagram post from James McAvoy
suggests that he'll be involved.
The Scot snapped himself having dinner with
fellow Professor X actor Patrick Stewart and
long time franchise producer Simon Kinberg,
captioning the pic "I can't wait for the summer,"
which is when production is scheduled to take
place.
Aquaman
DC fans got their first glimpse of natural
born badass Jason Momoa as Aquaman in Batman
versus Superman: Dawn of Justice last year,
and they'll be seeing him again in next year's
Justice League before his first solo flick
hits screens.
While the casting seems solid, question marks
remain over Aquaman after a series of destabilizing
changes behind the scenes, and whether it
will meet its December 21st, 2018 release
date.
DC Comics is already adjusting Aquaman's paper
counterpart to look and act more like Momoa's
bigscreen King of the Sea, so we'll be getting
a pretty good idea of what to expect when
he finally makes his real debut in Justice
League.
One thing's for certain, however: no one's
going to make fun of Aquaman after this.
No one.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!